today in our show stole Avengers and
that's all you need that's right today
I'm Batman I'm Batman I'm Batman I'm
Kevin Smith
so without a bill come in welcome in new
come in Bimini to cabaret yes we're
we're here on fat man Batman we're gonna
talk about some [ __ ] space related
shenanigans
perhaps our Wars time to talk a little
bit Star Wars folks mm-hmm
got some news for you yeah little bit
little bit little news but whatever we
got to cover it still you're holding it
down rogue one hit him with the hit him
with a dick hit him with a dick he made
some money son box-office dick it made a
few bucks
it made a few bucks all not much as of
last weekend
it has made nine hundred and eighty
three million dollars worldwide that's
it wow that's a lot of [ __ ] they're
gonna hit a billion very quickly yes
five hundred and two million
domestically although last weekend was
also the first weekend it was not number
one since it was released oh yeah you
know beat it in Vigors hidden figures
also a film about space there's your
trend yeah there's baby whether it's
space a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away or space a long time ago in a
galaxy right here yeah space and ladies
ladies who get to miss space
am I right jyn erso yeah and all the
ladies of hidden figures no I'm sorry
hidden fences it's quite a few times the
that's that's a lot of money
it's a [ __ ] ton of money that put that
on that's a lot of money Kevin Smith
right that is on par better than it's
not gonna do force awakens business but
they were never expecting that they
weren't I mean they they love this right
I mean there is no downside to this at
all no I mean force awakens was
something of an anomaly it made some to
million dollars worldwide also is
restarting the [ __ ] world it was the
first one back it was we got this folk
we got Han Solo back in a movie we got
you baka we have mutant Luke Skywalker
there was some oh yeah it was so much
everybody except for no-one's got nobody
nobody but done but the robot you come
to hate hey everybody it's the old
droids nobody likes anymore our doodie -
and c-3po go find a map or - [ __ ] you we
like the soccer ball droid more of him
less of the other one [ __ ] that guy [ __ ]
goldenrod are you talking to me
sorry I'm that that wrote one picture is
a dynamite flick we've blown it on this
show left to go the red top 10 lists
yeah yeah and then and easily - is like
fun a fun good time funny good times
funny good times and yes has made all of
the money we'll make a little bit more
of the money to get two billion dollars
because here's the thing Disney will
never take it out of theatres before it
makes a billion Mel yes this close it'll
be it'll be in theaters till April if it
has to be I read somewhere where they
were like it's not doing as well on
China's could whatever [ __ ] it's almost
made a billion dollars yeah I mean come
on that's that's like you're really
looking for a downside if you're like
well it's not doing as well in China
[ __ ] billion dollars for a found
money idea Jon Olsson they're gone like
hey why don't we tell the story of how
they got those plans into that [ __ ]
droid whatnot egress a billion dollars
later yes it was badass
thank you let's put a lady in it that
guy also co-created Photoshop him and
his brother in their spare time can you
imagine those guys they created
Photoshop which is also can be used as a
bird not just a man but they so they
created the term photoshopping mm-hmm
it's all their fault and in their spare
time well one of them came up with the
idea for real Guan basically every
shitty movie poster is their fault yeah
what are we gonna do assemble these
faces airbrush out these problems so
Miramax from like 20
I would say 2001 - well when they
stopped and Harvey and Bob left they
always just do the collection look I
always [ __ ] famous people look at the
money had nothing to do with this story
you know okay so that's rogue one
apparently did okay yeah I mean they're
not firing anybody over it and it meant
to be a placeholder until episode eight
which is next year maybe we'll get a
title soon yeah they still haven't
[ __ ] given title I thought I was like
maybe they'll tell us in front of rogue
one but they're like why bother yeah
rogue one is its own news item totally
we'll drop this a [ __ ] later on when
thinking probably around time when rogue
once goes to old video right that's yes
but the new Star Wars is called or on
the trailer that they'll attach to
guarding to galaxy to which they
absolutely will that's my that's what
they'll do that humanity mark works for
the LA Times bet on mark always bet on
mark either that or Beauty and the Beast
it'll be a Disney movie for sure beating
the Beast is in March II how get March
yeah who the [ __ ] said that March was
the movie mods when did this happen it
happened with 300 summer is May summer
bigger yeah it makes more awesome amen
that's right man they're gonna in a
world of global warming mmm make the
summer longer in begin it with movies in
beginning
the folks at star wars headquarters whoa
hello cheer that excuse me
Ponyo have announced yes categorically
there will be no digital version of
Carrie Fisher in the future correct and
you're you think you know what wait
there's one in rogue one mmm she was
still around when they did that but now
that carries past there you know she
finished all her work in Episode eight
mmm but none of the princes life stuff
has been done in Episode nine right so
they were all having conversations
apparently meetings about what to do
with the Princess Leia character post
carrie fisher's passing so they
announced you know just put every one of
these we're not gonna like shouldn't you
know right we're not gonna bring her to
life again right it would not surprise
me if because they're gonna have to
rewrite episode 8 after the fact
yeah to do something with Princess
Leia's character the same way they had
to do that with Paul Walker in Fast &
Furious 7 like he died midway through
production what the story is still use
of us-- pardon that fabric so you think
it's gonna be reflective and in Ryan's
right I think I'll have to go they'll
have to do something to close that
particular loop and it would not
surprise me if there is some digital
trickery to help massage that story they
said no but I don't think it's going to
be episode 9 Digital Princess Leia as a
character in the same way that say Peter
Cushing it's a character no they're like
we're not gonna do invent we're not
gonna continue that role but I wouldn't
be surprised if they used some digital
shenanigans to help massage what the
ending of episode they will be so we
understand why she's not enough
interesting so you're gonna film I can I
am I would just assume it's done like if
i'm ryan johnson i'm like my name is
fall us between y'all was doing 9 I get
to go they gotta figure that out but
we're good here mmm no you're right they
may want to yeah like he would not
surprise me at all if they go back in
and say alright how given what we shot
given what we have given what the rest
of the [ __ ] movie is how do we end
this in a way that resonates with
everybody that feels triumphant and also
feels like it's not leaving any
questions and also it feels has to play
like a send-off to like one of their not
just their biggest characters in the
saga but one of the original free actors
from yes like it needs to feel like a
tribute II it's a feel a bit like a
eulogy and usin to all of these things
while also still being a movie yeah and
that's gonna do some heavy lifting and
they got time I mean the movies not
until November of next year December of
next of this year yeah like 12 months so
yeah it's not an insurmountable problem
but it's gonna take some
whatever it is no digital Carrie Fisher
yeah going forward Princess Leia
speaking of Princess Leia leads you to
Han Solo speaking to han solo lead you
to the young mon-sol mm-hmm young Han
Solo I saw them a boy was named Alden
Ellen like in that movie by Warren
Beatty rules don't apply
hey he's good he's good Ruby's not a
little shade of a beat up an 80 year old
man your movies not good one bean but
the kid he's gonna play on Sol yeah good
nobody and dog lovers playing young
Lando mm-hmm I'm in now they've added
another cast member yeah oh so we had a
what's your face from Game of Thrones Oh
Khaleesi yes Emilia Clarke said her name
arc is playing a a new character and as
on yet titled character but I think if
she's not like it's not young layers and
rank that and now we've heard that
they've added the wood man they've added
wood to this movie this movie's got wood
woody harrelson father of all things
hemp has joined the cast of Star Wars
yeah Laura Dern is an episode 8 or not 8
I think 8 she's in the Rian Johnson
movie and now woody house uns we're the
Star Wars universe is expanding in ways
where did somebody had told you you know
[ __ ] ten years ago hey man you think
woody from Cheers over being a Star Wars
you'd be like now he's in white men
can't jump you can't be in a star let
her know Wildcat she can't do that yeah
but everybody loves woody harrelson
don't they and he sort of shifted into
this mandatory position in his like he
was a mentor to Katniss Everdeen that's
right in the Hunger Games now being a
mentor of sorts to Jung Han Solo yes
maybe he's a mentor to Han mmm he's on a
job he gets Mahon jaha
Nelson gives them hand job babies in a
little smuggler ooh bones my bones
Mugler alright I'm in I'm in yeah okay
[ __ ] whatever they could have been
like you know who we cast no you know
[ __ ] president-elect president united
states don't Trump I'd be like you know
what we need a job
it's another Star Wars movie mmm it's
all I give a [ __ ] about here who's the
whose mentor is I just want to see young
Han Solo so there it is man [ __ ] like
it's happenin Woody Harrelson in a Star
Wars movie you never thought I'd say it
but I'm looking forward to it I am too I
like it this is always [ __ ] dependable
[ __ ] okay moving on yes - tiny tidbits
from another part of the universe that
Disney owns yes we leave the Star Wars
galaxy where everything's doing just
fine they got a lot of money to the
marvel universe where everything is even
better and they gotta [ __ ] more loot
Disney owned anything that doesn't make
them billions of dollars not anymore
yeah now mister look what they own
Jersey Girls so I was gonna say that but
not anymore they are rid of that fella :
oh okay Thank You Harvey it's all yours
I don't know no man I got it made
they're smart I mean they went on an
unprecedented buying spree and bought
everything everybody wants I would and I
would also I've said this before I I
think they have Johnny Depp to thank mmm
they made all that pirates more money
based on people like that
voice they like him playing Captain Jack
mm-hmm that's why the movie let's be
honest right I don't tell you drove
everybody to that movie so those movies
make a [ __ ] ton of money that Disney has
just sitting around a piles of money
and they're like let's buy Star Wars and
Marvel like Johnny Depp you can trace
them back to us
yeah between Johnny Depp and the Pixar
money and
again bail and theme parks which do ya
an insane amount of money but still it's
like we'd like to make more of it how
much more other Walt would you like to
make all of it well I remember dude it
was like when they aunt when I had the
Disney stores like they couldn't sell
boy toys
they would try there would be like Peter
Pan figure or Captain Hook figure and
just was they were always kind of like
girls strong because the princess and
boys okay they didn't have their boy
thing so they went out and bought the
boy thing which was marvel and marvels
not just a boy thing no Marvel comes
with its 50/50 comes with [ __ ] girls
as well women men women so same thing
there they were just like oh we just
wanted to plug in our boy hole which
sounds better but they like in doing so
we've got a bunch of [ __ ] people and
then they went and bought another
[ __ ] both gender franchise Star Wars
yep that's a boy thing either it's girl
thing boy boys and girls so they're
they're got a covered man how long
before you think I mean and I know that
that there was a press release a while
ago saying that Spielberg was coming
back to do another Indiana Jones with
Harrison Ford in it and George Lucas
nowhere near it I don't know why they
gotta say it like that because people
remember remember the Crystal Skull but
how long before we get the young Indiana
Jones reboot they said never while
Harrison is while he's still around mmm
so take that for what you will I don't
know I think I read that somewhere I
don't know who they is right I think I
read somewhere they were like never
while Harrison's around would we ever
replace with a young Indiana Jones I
think I mean that's bold if you were
gonna do it though we all know Chris
Pratt seems like the guy who'd you go
with I don't know I don't think so
because I've got a play period like it's
gotta be I mean for my money if I don't
see any image I was fighting Nazis then
then we've made some kind of mistake
still and you know reinvented but I
don't know I still I feel like there's a
world in which a slightly younger nathan
fillion gets that job mmm
you know well so what first we got a
turn back time for Nathan billion I I
would always turn back time for Nathan
Fillion I would take off my top and it
shown to Nathan king of my castle rule
thank you we got there try to be clever
yeah okay so we're in the world of the
Avengers infinity war casting you can't
stop this Avengers movie from happening
you don't want it's gonna be [ __ ]
amazed balls at one point there's gonna
be 68 Marvel characters in costume on
camera once I've heard can't imagine I'm
gonna buck that number 138 212 it's
gonna be amazed 616 model characters at
once on the screen they were already
looking at two movies that are gonna be
on a top 10 list of mine for those years
those roots are boys they know what
they're doing mm-hmm
so yes they've cast well they're adding
nebula they're adding Karen Gillan she
played nebula in guardians the galaxy
mm-hmm stoked to shape ah she's loving
it she's like oh my god I was happy to
be in [ __ ] guardians of galaxy now
you're telling me I'm gonna be in an
Avengers movie which should be expected
she was Thanos thought mm-hmm right yeah
well good for her yes but this other one
is interesting we spoke about the Sun
Babylon let's address this year the
Dinklage yeah as the Dinklage you wanna
see someone's dick hanging out dinklage
peter dinklage if i open the bar that
was supposed to be like an Irish pub I
would call it in the dinkledge nice
right nice and everything is small but
potent I'm fine I was gonna try to tag
up on that but I'm okay
Tyrion himself Peter Dinklage has been
added to the cast of Avengers infinity
war mm-hmm they have not said who he's
playing yet the internet though slewed
the things out and has given us some
choices one of them which is puck Oh
character that Thanos has been known to
interact with I believe in in Infinity
Gauntlet but is puck would be in the X
Universe that wouldn't be alpha flight I
don't think it's the same puck same
different puck different book okay but I
still don't think it's going to be that
book and then there was another
suggestion but I don't think is it but
then somebody floated this one mmm MODOK
MODOK come on if you're watching this
show you better know who to [ __ ] moto
just in case your mom tuned in for the
first time come here
hi mom MODOK tell them what it stands
for machine only designed on killing for
killing anything so no machine operated
machine on machine only designed so
ridiculous that you're him whatever but
MODOK is like a junkie chase in a chair
with tiny little hands and legs one of
like Marvel's seminal [ __ ] villains
from the comics looked cool on the page
but you never imagine you see him in the
real world they're talking about baby
all right
and here's why tell me one of the
authors of this infinity war screenplay
mmm was also the author of what
co-author of Captain America - yes and
he in an interview said man I tried to
get MODOK into that movie dude I got no
love nobody who else would back me up in
the room that those two pieces of
distant information that old willingness
to put MODOK into it a Captain America
movie which makes sense he's given
America's villain to Peter Dinklage
being cast has a lot of people
speculating that he's going to play
MODOK and in a world where we're getting
ego the Living Planet MODOK is not
anymore
the table than that that's true so I
mean I I I buy that I kind of would
prefer that he didn't play a character
that was so high like even if it's a
movie just opens with them all fighting
mode of have to go off by thanos that be
badass
I'm into it cuz he's earthbound like
MODOK he's not like I'm from outer space
Captain America and Dinklage walking
between two worlds as well he was Trask
in in one walking between worlds within
a world you know we're all Marvel people
are a Marvel X and Marvel or Marvel Fox
and marvel marvel marvel marvel more
that's right who's bolivar trask yeah
good for you Peter Dinklage uh uh yeah
well whoever is he's gonna be an asset
to the movie [ __ ] can act like
and you know a lot of people of course
we all know Game of Thrones go back and
watch state this station hmm
hey you know what else go back and watch
underdog more sinister maybe he doesn't
want you to watch it no I would still do
it be a completist
but yeah him in this movie I mean look I
already they already had my money mmm
stop making it better that just keeps
going after I've gone like no no no it's
already [ __ ] gonna be amazing but you
throw a little [ __ ] Dinklage in there
mmm or you throw a little MODOK in there
Dinklage as MODOK I bend a knee and give
you my fealty for the rest of my life
Marvel nu which I already give ya
there's one more thing out of TCA the
Television Critics Association has a
winter press tour oh yeah and they
parade all of the network's parade their
wares in front of the press
yes and so there's this new Fox FX show
called Legion coming out on the on the
FX created by ya know Holly who did
Fargo which is [ __ ] awesome if you
haven't seen Fargo go do that and then
the idea of that dude doing a sort of
new mutant see kind of show awesome it
was announced that that show will not
cross over with any other next car yeah
I saw that
they're gonna sort of silo that off so
that it doesn't have any tendrils in
anything yeah they're gonna be like it's
got mutants and you're such a thing as
but it's not directed they will have
nothing to do with Wolverine or
Apocalypse or any of this
but along with that news Fox announced
that they were going to be commissioned
a pilot script for an x-men show a show
that is adjacent to the movie correct
said in that universe right that Lauren
Shuler Donner has a hand and it's about
[ __ ] time just sitting there if you
got all that X property and [ __ ] there's
sounds and [ __ ] mutants oh and a lot
of networks that need a show
absolutely that's smart there's like
even if it was just [ __ ] teen kids in
a boarding school doing wacky [ __ ] that
makes sense I wonder if they have the
rights to do TV spin-offs no no no based
on that old marble deal and my must have
something because they're doing it
that's exciting news
yeah so that's that's the mobile you
news there it is
there it is it's always we got freemen
what's better than that take that news
and shove it up your [ __ ] fan hole
mmm can they just wiggle it a little bit
just a little bit
that's a groove where you girl it just
little bit finally mark never mind
Warner Brothers indeed never mind DC on
the big screen okay DC on the small
screen is what I'm talking about
my Supergirl episode is airing January
23rd so by the time you're watching this
this may go up the same day if that's
the case watch it tonight Monday night
Supergirl returns and I direct the
episode we go to space space on space
with people with makeup like it was
flat-out news fun yeah it's really
really cool and lots of flying good
times so it airs Monday hopefully this
is Monday watch it tonight mm-hmm but by
this point I guess maybe they'll I can
say it I am heading back up to WoW
Vancouver in February February 5th or
6th and doing another episode of super
son-of-a-bitch
much like this guy enough to bring me
back one more time one more time one
more time so I'm gonna go direct another
Super Girl so see if it's see if I've
earned that by watching the Super Girl
that airs tonight on the CW on the C
double shell Melissa Benoist is just
phenomenal she was actually a very good
Muslim terrorists in patriot yes I was
surprised at host but girl you nasty
girl yeah yeah she's yeah dad did you
ever see that movie where the Huck Finn
movie time our Ganga thieves nothing no
Banda thieves she's in that too she
plays like a Becky Becky Thatcher no
that's cool it's a good boy okay there
it is folks
check out Supergirl do it tonight man on
the CW in the DC Universe Greg Berlanti
son that's it that's all the news we got
for you tonight that's all that's it
it's enough for fat man I'm back now I'm
Kevin Smith I'm look tune in next time
same bat time same bat Channel my guest
amor youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
you